I accidentally became a meme and this is
that story my name is Andres Erato
that people might know me as hide the
pain Herald before taking stock photos I
was working as an electric engineer my
specialty was lighting technologies the
stock photos began when a photographic
contacted me when he saw my selfies on
the social media and he was saying that
he was seeking a character like me and
invited me to shoot some images this
happened almost 10 years ago after the
first photo shoots the photographer
really liked the pictures so he righted
me back several times I was for instance
a doctor a university professor husband
a painter and many others I first
realised when I had become a meme
several months after the first photo
shoots I was curious but my pictures
were used for so I made a reverse image
search and I discovered myself in
different advertisements as a professor
or or a doctor but some months later
when I repeated that search I discovered
the first mean and that was the point
when I realized that I had became
at first it was horrifying when I
encountered the first means because
there was some really rude or disgusting
jokes with me so I wanted to please
throw all the pictures and close down
all the website that they appeared but
that was not a real solution it took
several years they'd like to accept the
situation but it has brought me several
new opportunities at first people didn't
believe that I'm a real living person
they thought the memes were trying to
Photoshop creation when I embraced this
I revealed my identity on a Russian
social media site and after that I can
say that for the bad or rude or
disgusting needs disappeared at first I
did not consider myself as famous but
later more and more people stopped me on
the street asking for a selfie
I do this always willingly because I see
the joy in the eyes of these people and
it's so good to make other people happy
I had the opportunity to cooperate with
the biggest brands like coca-cola they
invited me for a shooting when I had to
fly in a wind tunnel it was very very
exciting I enjoyed it very much
now there is a much bigger challenge
inside a comedy movie about the high the
pain story my management is planning and
talking with potential investors
surprisingly I got lots of messages each
day on my Facebook and Instagram
channels from people asking for help in
the everyday life I try to show to my
fans that they should be happy even
during the difficult times in their
lives and I guess memes can have in
these periods to overcome the everyday
annoyances even though this unexpected
event happened I still consider myself
the same old guy and Roger Otto
[Music]